hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester this is the tata steel
india edition with the the rapid event
like I said first we're gonna have the
three days of rapid before going into
the Blitz section so it's yummy pony
versus Vishwanathan Anand wish you want
a very nice game against Wesley in round
two and
napal lost a very nice game to Magnus
and round two so now they face off
against each other and this is a game
from round three so the last game of day
one let's see how it goes nappa with the
white pieces opens with c4 so the
English is on the board we have E 5 and
sorry about that something seems to be
off with the interface and the g3 with
Knight to f6 continuing develop and
Bishop to G to end Bishop to c5 so going
for rapid development with knife 2 C 3
and C 6 now preparing well not before
but d5 with Knight to f3 are challenging
the pawn here inviting e4 so on and
Gosford we have efore Knights the h4 end
now d5 and this position has been
reached in the in the Isle of Man
tournament
Anton Davi de haro headed against
Alexander Grichuk and seek after sandy
if I was played guitar or won that game
but here we have d4 and it's a new move
so already as I move 7 we have a
completely new game and the point is
white once he captures on d3 which would
give white a lot of development after
seek after Sun d5 Knight captures a
knight capture seek actress and Queen
captures you would maybe force the black
to keep the King into in the center of
the board for a bit longer as the d5
pawn is under attack so here after d4 on
it says and not interested just goes
back Bishop to e7
C capture Sun d5 with C capture Sun d5
and now both players Castle we have
castles castles and f3 never challenged
as the center as we usually say you want
to challenge the central pawn with a
less central pawn so such is the case
here and you do ruin your pawn structure
a bit but you get an open file semi open
file for your rook so knight Knight to
c6 by Anand and now Knight to f5 so
probably neppo new
Jarro versus Grishka and he prepared
this d4 line and he he had this knight
to age 45 more prepared and it seems
like a very annoying night and you don't
really have a good way of kicking it
away from there you don't want to give
up your bishop for the night as this is
a good bishop even though it's still
undeveloped and you don't want to play
something like g6 because you lose the
game on the spot due to the f6 Knight
being well after Knight captures a Queen
Catherine's you have to defend the
knight Bishop g5 is just deadly although
you can for the moment prevent a rook
captures but now just Knight captures
and you cannot capture back due to the
pin so once you move the Queen just
captures with check and black falls
apart so for the moment this is this
here is a monster night we have Knight
to e4 by Anand and now comes route back
to f1 opening up this bishops diagonal
we have brush up to f6 putting pressure
on the d4 pawn now and just now III
strengthening the center we have Knight
captures and c3b captures and just
Bishop to e6 finally our black is
allowed to continue development we have
looked the b1 by nepo putting pressure
on the b7 pawn here and Anand goes Queen
to d7 defense and also attacks as the
knight here is under attack twice now we
have E for buy nipple and here Anand has
to play a captures d captors on e4 there
is no other way around it but Anand
doesn't capture here after E for on goes
rook f2 e 8 and this doesn't work why it
doesn't work feel free to pause the
video here and try to figure out why it
doesn't work while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations and finding
such a nice idea and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's Knight to h6
but it's not enough to only see the
first move I'm sure y'all thought of
this one now of course if pawn captures
rook captures the white is clearly
better here you've messed up the black's
pawn structure the Queen has a very easy
entry to the attack Bishop captures and
h6 is coming
black falls apart here so of course uh
none goes King to h8 but now comes roof
captures and f6 s all of you already
yeah I figured it out G captures on f6
and now Queen to f3 and this Queen to f3
is the prize move because now there's
the Queen to f6 mate as the knife covers
the g8 square but also you're just
winning back your peace because pawn
captures here traps the bishop on e6
well also attacks the night so here you
woulda just went back the piece and
you've missed a black's pawn structure
so even that is enough so how to defend
against mate and other threats well it's
not easy for example if f5 let the
prevent Queen to f6 Bishop to g5 with
the threat of Bishop to f6 mate is very
strong so after King to rook g8 you're
gonna deliver check recast the block and
now you're just gonna pick up the pawn
back and you're gonna win back your
piece you're gonna win back material and
of course win the game very easily so
another another idea as Queen to d8 to
just guard upon here but now you just
capture it hey you just win back the
piece after Bishop captures you're gonna
go Queen captures Queen captures and now
Bishop captures here and after all is
said and done you have two bishops for a
rook which is of course completely
winning there's no good way to defend
the f7 pawn so completely lost for black
so here on and when King to g7 he said
I'm gonna try and defend the pawn this
way ah but still it pretty much runs
into the same idea with pawn captures on
d5 now winning back the piece Bishop
captures on d5 and here never played
Knight to f5 check and it was in this
position that we found and resigned the
game unmoved 22 as we pretty much go
into the same line after the king moves
king h8 you just pick up the piece and
after Queen captures Bishop captures
again we end up in a position where it's
two bishops for a rook are completely
winning position for white and Anand of
course knows this and he doesn't want to
drag it on so that's a very nice game
from round from round three of the Tata
Steel chess India rapid Edition I do
hope you enjoyed it nice nice comeback
for neppo after losing that game to
Magnus and we're gonna show one more
game from round three and then we're
gonna discuss the standings a bit so I
do hope you enjoy that I would like to
thank David Gill and David rib for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel rapid edition in India are
checking often your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day